I never really used to make calls or
sales calls or anything like that cuz
you know from the building guy I work
with my hands I found some leads and I
see everyone else making calls and um I
typed in the number and I was so nervous
and I was just staring at my phone about
10 minutes just to trying to make it
call to his landord in I pressed call
Button phoned him and said oh hi um
looking to do a company L he was like no
no not interested go away you waste my
time and I was like ouch yeah and I was
just like what am I doing what I was
doing because I create a script but then
every time I'd get a no I'd think okay
maybe my script's wrong I tweak my
script tweak my script you know now now
I'll get on the phone to a landlord just
pick up the phone talk to him and it's
fine